on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
connaît quelques-uns des prénoms refusée
par l'état civil en 2021 oui c'est
toujours assez amusant cocasse pour le
moins les successeurs de bâbord et
tribord ou d'astérix et obélix vous en
souvenez alors cette année on retrouve
le mot lucifer faut oser le prénom qui
dément même si c'est aussi le nom d'une
série à la mode faut le porter quand
même en cm2 de s'y faire alors après on
attribue une liste de prénoms rigolo il
ya nutella qui est clairement pas celui
de passionnés diététique enjoy en
hommage à michael jackson on retrouve
ikea c'était une émission tout à fait
exceptionnel que toi tu as bien diriger
un peu comme laurent
ruquier
non faut pas dire renier tout le temps
faux pas forget a même interrompre sans
arrêt
la table tu vois ce que je veux dire aux
blessés aller jusqu'au bout de ma phrase
comme ça veut dire oui que comment tu
t'appelles toit du
prince william comme prénom composé je
veux dire vraiment un signal inspiré
williams et à bob l'eponge metallica
clafoutis anomalies d'anomalies au
tableau bon celle là c'est vraiment le
pont peau de la connerie celle ci elle
vaut le détour ces loyers
étaient ces mêmes mais anne couture même
les fringues sont sales
mais pour ces couches et aux poubelles
sont sales de téléphone date de 70 cm a
fait couler il au monde sait que c'est
une folie que tu regardes pendant une
demi-heure il ya des gens qui rient au
dix huitième degré dre salle en très
attention au boulet de canon du corsaire
encore certain
pas les bâtons tu vas en corse comme ça
j'aime bien qu'en fait ça à sin la
taille 6 e cécile le thème ces pirates
pas défilé de mode en attendant je vais
retourner kiev je vais tomber voix
requis
[Applaudissements]
jeudi globalement ce que beaucoup 90 ans
mais tous pensent de toi et deuxièmement
il a
fait quoi toi dans ta
mère
iachtchouk rezaï gourde mont rose comme
on a road aux jetons weedon jeune miss
tier storage mire mais vos pieds vous
n'avez pas posé une question sur l'appel
des scientifiques 1400 sur l'urgence
climatique et le fait que justement le
débat présidentiel ne parle pas de la
catastrophe en cours etc j'ai ouvert
justement avec une catastrophe
écologique sur les varier de merlan
globale qui sont dans le golfe de
gascogne si vous aviez vu au logis si
vous aviez vu le début de l'émission
vous auriez vu courir et vert avec ça je
pense que toute l'idée du changement
climatique est une ruse avec une
motivation politique
je prie pour les scientifiques je prie
pour la science vous savez la fausse
science ça existe c'est comme les faits
cnio êtes dans la politique s'en mêle
tout est corrompu
tout cela fait partie du jugement de
dieu c'est lui qui va sauver la terre
elle a transformé en paradis
qu'il faut pourrir la vie des non
vacciné sans connaître qu'ils vivent au
quotidien
il peut pas s'attendre à autre chose et
il a tenu ces propos là sur une sur une
émission de grande écoute il a attisé la
et après il n'ya faire ça majorettes
meilleur niveau
ni rien
oui
et rien alors que c'est lui qui l'a
décoré ch après saddam qui sait plus de
père fouettard comme ça delà de la
gueule de la politique ou de 2e les
dires de deux des rapports humains
alors vous savez tout vrai vous savez
tout et rien d'autre je trouve voilà
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas grand
chose
la quintessence de ce que vous avez dit
ce soir c'est pas grand chose en fait
parce que vous nous alerter de quoi des
discours de désamour de l'extrême droite
comment elles entendent qu'en france ça
commence à me saouler meriem palun barre
en tête qui dit des conneries qui dit
qu'on aime dictature qui compara temps
qui compatit qu'on
arrête tu dis des conneries du raid sais
pas de quoi tu as déjà insultés mais
j'ai pensé
bienvenue chez des excités du dimanche
d'être emprisonnés
vous vous trompez rassurez moi mais
est-ce que je suis juge est ce que je
suis policier là c'est parce que je suis
proche de temps en ce n'est d'être juge
de menus des jaunes d'oeufs lancés d1p
d'appeler de passer des coups de fil de
données des métèques des choses en en
loose et comme ça ce sera le jour proche
je vous ai dit je ne suis pas venu pour
souffrir tuer pour manger pour casser le
vin c'est pas la peine
vous faites ça me regarde le paradis des
hammers qui se passe
la droite pourrir la vie des gens mais
tous font enlever les allées les
indemnités chômage en janvier
c'est d'une violence incroyable et vous
vous vous êtes là en train de le débat
parce qu'il a eu un peu atypique et
venir vous savez ce que nous on vit
depuis des mois et des mois
c'est pas que ça mine le moral mais bon
ouais ça
[Musique]
on va dire que c'est la vie sa joie un
poil de derrière
[Rires]
pas simplement
payer pour rigoler c'est trop bien oh là
là quoi qu'il arrive faire deux heures
d'émission et de payer 30 40 mille euros
c'est toute façon par rapport au boulot
tu fais certainement trop pour tous les
gens qui nous écoutent la vérité c'est
que toutes ces têtes là elles font
vendre de la pub à tf1 comme les photos
il faut vendre des maillots au barça à
madrid au psg et qu'évidemment c'est pas
ton travail qu'on paye c'est une image
et comment ton image rapporte de
l'argent à ceux qui te paye alors vous
avez joué avec combien de fois avec nous
aujourd'hui
et aujourd'hui voilà c'était
donc c'est pas moi c'est une question
chance un nouvel emoji d'un homme qui
attend un enfant va faire son apparition
depuis 2019 les émaux j qui représente
des personnes sont élargies à toutes les
couleurs de peau et à tous les genres
masculin féminin et non définie c'est
dans un souci de représentation des
personnes trans que ce nouvel et mogi et
donc ajouté mais il devrait être aussi
utilisé pour autre chose puisque
l'encyclopédie de référence et mauges
ipdia explique que ce nouvel et logis
peut très bien aussi représentés et bien
le fait d'avoir trop manger ou trop bu
cité la résolution du nouvel an qu'on ne
tient jamais celle que moi je n'arrive
pas à tenir
boire de l'alcool - enfin - voir
elle est tellement peur je veux
absolument commencer attisé est allé on
ressemble aux graves la france et oui
des toilettes liberté égalité fraternité
c'est une preuve d'amour
oui et oui après
73 enfants de la patrie
jour de toi tu arrives et des gaz même
si c'est un peu gênant nous en avons
tous il faut bien qu'ils sortent nous en
libérons une quinzaine par jour en
moyenne soit 2 litres d'air
etc gaz en plus d'émettre des sons
peuvent aussi être la cause d'odeurs
désagréables
un ballonnement qu'est ce que ça va
devenir eybens est appelé à devenir une
flatulence ou plus vulgairement 1 p
alors on va péter c'est bon coupez